more than 800 000 syrians are registered
as refugees with the United Nations in
Lebanon
but hundreds of thousands more live here
many undocumented the government is now
enforcing tougher restrictions including
revoking Refugee status for those who
leave
in addition dozens of syrians who don't
have legal residency have been deported
in recent weeks
officials say regulating their presence
is necessary for Lebanon a nearly
bankrupt country with limited resources
some of the displaced syrians are here
for security reasons and they can't go
back but there are others who don't have
issues with the Syrian government and
their Villages are now safe there is
also another group who are here for
economic reasons
anti-refugee rhetoric has increased
recently as have calls for them to
return home
but syrians are afraid as human rights
groups have documented cases of
returnees being arrested the Syrian
government requested list of names and
they were checked whether they were
involved in any activities that are
considered to be illegal or terrorist as
far as the Syrian government is
concerned and that is again another
um obstacle for people to to to go back
the repatriation can only be done in
coordination with the Syrian state
some Arab Nations have re-established
relations with Damascus but there's
still no consensus on reintegrating the
Syrian president Bashar al-assad into
the Arab League the president has been
isolated since his brutal Crackdown on
Peaceful protests more than a decade ago
the issue of refugee returns as well as
granting them amnesty are part of a
broader political settlement that's
still under discussion but throughout
the conflict Assad has shown little
willingness to compromise along with his
allies he has made funds for
reconstruction a precondition for
returns
if you are asking whether the Syrian
government accepts the return of the
displaced Syria is a state and the issue
of displaced people like other issues is
being used for political benefits and
this is normal all countries seek to
reap benefits from various issues
all the while a humanitarian issue
that's been affecting millions of
syrians has become a political tool
Lebanon